okay I would like to welcome you all to
the 1st day-
based on your Saturday lectures that is
organized by the Year Program in Iranian
studies here I would like to welcome our
guest speaker professor Sanjay soup
ammonia and in a moment I'm going to say
a few words about him but I thought
first perhaps I should say a few words
about the Yoshiaki lectures and
fellowships
we are very fortunate to receive the
fundings from the Persian heritage
foundation over the course of the past
three years for the establishment of the
intellectual series as well as for the
fellowship that is going to start this
year that's largely thanks to the
generosity of professor I shall give
himself off a home his lectures were
named he has been in addition to being
the doing of Iranian studies for many
years and the æther in chief of
encyclopaedia iranica among many other
projects that some of you might be
familiar and maybe a great contributor
to the field of fashion and Iranian
studies has been also very supportive of
a person either Iranian studies in North
America as well as in Europe I believe
he must have created at least four or
five lectureships or fellowships or
permanent positions in various
universities through the fashion
heritage foundation so we very much
welcome it and we hope that it's going
to continue over the future years and if
we go by the speaker today we hope that
the prospects for this lecture ceiling
is going to be very bright in future as
well
a few things also should be pointed out
this is going to be these lectures that
is today tomorrow and Thursday that we
have a roundtable all the proceedings
are going to be recorded and posted
refined in here iranian studies website
at AG mila for future references or for
people who because of the weather today
that did not cooperate or for any
reasons have not been able to be here
with us so uh please spread the word
that in future this is going to be
posted professor scientist subrahmanyam
is a scholar historian of South Asia I
would say not only South Asia but Indian
Ocean and global history and the old a
neighboring land to South Asia is a
figure that it does not really require
an introduction because anybody who has
been able remotely interested in history
of this area all the neighboring regions
has come across numerous contributions
that he has made up as being one of the
most prolific and was one of the most
imaginative historians of early modern
times I would say he is a graduate from
Delhi University and taught in Delhi
University of a number of years
afterwards in Paris and in Oxford before
her in 2002 being appointed as the first
holder I'm sorry in 2002 at Oxford being
appointed at the first order of a newly
created chair of India instrument
culture and then since 2005 he moved to
you
of California Los Angeles where he
currently is a distinguished professor
of history and everything and Jeanne
stone chair in the University of
California at UCLA professor Subramanian
conducts not only offers lectures but
also works with a number of graduate
students and in addition to that I don't
know how he manages to write so many
wonderful works that we are the
recipients he was for a number of years
also served as the founding director of
the UCLA Center for India and South Asia
um he is also the editor managing editor
of the Indian economic and social
history review he since 2014 has been a
member of psychology France and he
spends part of his time in in Paris and
part of assignment the scientist being
in a great demand his list of books and
publications is too long for us to
mention here and I'm sure many of you
can easily get access to it
most recently however it should be
mentioned that he has the brought out
2017 Harvard University Press Europe's
India words people's Empire
1600 to 1800 which I have been lucky to
receive a copy from him and I cannot
wait to actually read passages online
but to read it in print he has these
great commanders as many of you might
notice of a number of languages and kind
of a very in-depth knowledge of the
archives and primary sources all over
the world I would say particularly our
precious for the circus
this period that he is engaging
Portuguese and the presence of the
Portuguese in the culture of India in
Indian Ocean region has been a source of
great scholarship an interest to him as
well as a number of other languages and
the multiple collaborations with among
others is not a viola who produced just
two notes the book on the Indo Persian
travel in the age of discoveries 1400 to
1800 that many of you and I can see in
this room familiar written that studied
it covering a range of Persian speaking
or Persian writers interpersonal writers
to travel in the region mostly number
cell and which is part of the focus of
this part of the interest and focus of
this book I would like also to say a few
words but the actual choice of this
topic I first approached process of
Romania because I was very inspired by
his scholarship by his very I would say
articulates imaginative and witty at the
same time style of writing and his
extraordinary command of the literature
and of course it occurred to me he has
given a series of lectures collège de
France and Europe and India and I
thought it would be an interesting to
try to look at perhaps an expansion of
that extension of that topic and
somewhat independent from that one about
the Indo Persian
connections being that is interest these
days is very much is it connected
histories and this may provide it kind
of very interesting avenue to explore
given that perhaps Iran and India are
among the the exchanges the cultural
exchanges among commercial and cultural
exchanges between Iran and India
probably one of the oldest in the world
going back probably two and a half
millennia millennia and I don't expect
that process Subramanyam is going to
talk about all of that era but it's
important to remember that this dialogue
is a very old old one and has continued
over the centuries almost without any
rupture
even if takes the case of the lake and
quickly the sustaining gupta exchanges
and the amount of text and literature
that came from India to Iran translated
in totality and scutella were translated
into Arabic and spread all over the
Islamic world among them the famous
calendar Damona is one example also the
game of board games of general Shang
the chess chaturanga in India and that
came to Iran is another example what he
is going to do for us however in his
lectures and I think probably i'ma
blushes to least briefly the synopsis
that he has provided for us he wants a
kind of a general introduction this is
political economic and cultural
connections between Iran and India very
striking feature of the savage mobile
era in the 16th 17th and early 18th
centuries these connections were also
affected and at times heavily modified
by the action of European actors in the
western Indian Ocean these two lectures
seek to address this set of issues the
analysis of which has seen a number of
important contributions in the past by
unions Indian and this
scholars topic of his first lecture that
I can frontier in the time of the
Sultanate again I'm quoting him we'll
examine Iranian relations with the deck
and beginning from the time of the dates
back many dynasty and then extending
into the time of the Sultanate of I'm a
cigar a bridge or food and Golconda a
particular focus will be on the credence
of Iranian immigrants in the Deccan some
of whom belongs to the elite groups but
others were coming from more humble
backgrounds
I live the rest of it to a process of
Romanian but before I would end it is
probably an appropriate time to thank
some of my some of the people here at
Yale who very crucial of their
participation and support for this
organization of these lectures in
particular I would like to thank David
idiot who worked conceptually and
internal organization of these lectures
has been really valuable and very
crucial to debate that this legislation
and go back to thanking also to thank
here
tadhana BN and also came on the joy both
of them also helps with the lectures I
would like to thank the an
administration of the maximilien center
console and Middle East Studies and all
the supporting cells has also been
received from Yale in terms of in terms
of corresponds to ship with the oceans
and lectures thank you very much safely
this kind of prolonging that is longer
than I expected
introduction so processor Romanian it's
all yours now
[Applause]
yeah yeah I think it's here for you
sunita night included touch this is
August we want to try to make sure that
it was measuring device protector thank
you very much thank you a bus for that
very kind introduction a bus who in a
very funny way has in a manner of
speaking become my ham chef because we
both are Angelenos in one fashion or
another in giving these lectures and
when a bus actually invited me to give
them I thought it was a funny
coincidence that it's actually exactly
25 years since I published a paper
called Iranians abroad which appeared in
1992 in the journal of asian studies and
for a few years was actually the most
cited paper I published it was
eventually overtaken by another paper
called connected histories and when I
wrote the paper already 25 years ago I
was all very conscious of being in the
debt of a number of scholars who had
gone before me and you know standing on
the shoulders of giants and all that
some of these scholars were scholars off
and from South Asia I'm thinking of
people like Haroon can share money very
notably the Pakistani scholar as well
Islam who was a real pioneer of
indo-iranian diplomatic relations and
this study but I was actually especially
thinking of someone whom I was very
close to in the 1990s and we left a real
mark on my own intellectual trajectory a
little bit forgotten unfortunately today
which was the the great french scholar
and Orientalist jean back and he's
someone whom i will be referring to from
time to time in the course of today's
lectures over began his career in the
early 1950s studying the timurid to
suffer which he had a very very
important article which some of you will
know
KOMO time alone comical arrow icon Kili
will put more or less something like
that and then he proceeded in the course
of the sixties to extend his interest
into the larger Indian Ocean world if
the 70s became a great scholar of the
Portuguese Empire and so in a way has a
lot to do with the kinds of teams which
I will be touching upon today so where
to begin so let me begin by surprising
you a little bit let me see if I can
actually manage to get the sorting yes
so I do not know how many of you will
immediately look at this and say I know
what this is this is the humble Lhari
right
what is the Lhari the Lhari is a very
strange as they say fish hook shaped
silver coin which dominated the western
Indian Ocean in the 15th century right
it is the most common form of silver
currency extending between the Persian
Gulf South Arabia western India and Sri
Lanka in the 15th century
it comes as its name suggests from the
town of large it then continues to have
a career in the 16th century in the
early 17th century these are actually
other shah hilary's which are produced
by the Sultanate of Bijapur and in fact
it then continues to have a career much
later one of the most important
quantitatively hordes of Lawry's is
found in Kampala near candy in central
Sri Lanka and these are of course by the
time somewhat degenerated lorries in the
sense that they don't have much of a
silver content they become largely
copper coinage but they are very very
interesting in terms of their form and
of course there are all kinds of folk
reasons that are given for why they take
the shape that they do which is the fact
that for instance they can be apparently
more conveniently tucked into the folds
of a sarong whether this is a good
reason to shape a coin in this in this
is an open question now the lhari
incidentally continues as the name of
the national currency of at least one
Caucasian state even today but of course
it's now taken a very different form
from this one so the humble Lari is a
good place to begin because in a way
this shows you how the monetary culture
of a southern Iranian town and it's
already run in town which is in fact
very very important as we see in the
15th century which became somewhat less
important in the 16th century so in the
early 17th century it was still a a halt
for Peter of the Lavallee who spent a
certain amount of time there and who
actually in his collection which is
deposited in the Vatican you can still
find manuscripts which have been copied
in lard so you can actually see how
there is from this interior southern
Iranian town a kind of a circulation and
we'll see it's not just a circulation of
objects it's also a circulation of
people some of whom are actually quite
important and interesting people
including someone whom I will be talking
about which is a certain Assad can Lari
in the first half of the sixteenth
century
now we know that direct relations
between the west coast of India and Iran
why the ports of the Persian Gulf long
predated the foundation of the bimini
Sultanate around
13:47 the family Sultanate was founded
in the Deccan by Allah the infant
Mohammad Shah who had been earlier
titles of her han and in the time that
he founded this kingdom in the middle of
the 14th century conquering ports such
as carne and soul were already very
prominent in the trade across the Indian
Ocean they had been so since the 13th
century though the extent of the trade
was probably surpassed in that period by
regions such as Gujarat to the north and
Kerala to the south but already in the
preceding centuries Muslim traders from
the West had gradually settled along
this the Konkan coast that you don't see
here which we will see presently
and had begun to
have an influence already at the time of
the rashtrakutas and then the other
words of David Goethe and one of the
consequences of this is of course the
creation more or less at this time of
hybrid communities such as the Neriah so
who even today continued to play a role
both in this region in fact all the way
across into the tunnel country now the
novice Scots were heavily invested in
maritime activity but there were also
important Mariners ship owners and ship
captains now a steady trickle of
evidence from the Arab traders and
geographers beginning with al masud II
in the 10th century makes it clear that
the Konkan Coast was quite familiar to
them and that merchants from Yemen South
Arabia as well as the Persian Gulf
regularly frequented the area now
merchants from the Iranian part of
Seraphin is in and verdant seem in
particular to have known and settled in
a place they call say moon but which is
told and even if the exact size of these
Muslim trade communities appear the
times exaggerated in the sources there's
little doubt that these traders
considerably preceded the armies of the
Delhi Sultanate when they penetrated the
area under the rule of the tabla dynasty
they also maintained contact with the
Sultanate that had emerged in the
coastal regions of West Asia in the
declining centuries of the Abbasid
Caliphate now while I think the homilies
Sultanate in the second half of the 14th
century made claims to control the ports
of the Konkan the area in fact remained
somewhat autonomous of them for very
long periods however since the Sultanate
also had no effective dealings with the
East Coast to the so called coromandel
coast because of difficulties presented
by the resistance of the so called ready
kingdom of country wieder
the generals and rulers after bahaminy
sultanate returned periodically to the
task of subjugating the west coast
especially in order to gain direct
access to the strategic horse trade
coming from the station now the early
decades of the bahaminy rule we know are
difficult to analyze because there is a
great positive contemporary sources and
so historians often turn to the later
narrative histories from the end of the
sixteenth century so
sources like the great chronicle of
muhammad qasim Hindu Shastra body known
as Pharisee or Syed Ali Tabata by again
roughly his contemporary and both of
these sources and others mentioned that
the bahaminy dynasty's founder
assertively claimed descent from the
pre-islamic sicilian rulers of Iran
though actually this is clearly a a
false claim he or he himself probably
came from cosna and but he intended that
this claim should be taken taken very
seriously the architectural historian
method shabooey has noted that in a good
many of the early bahaminy structures
for instance in the city of Goldberger
we can find a sicilian emblem in the
form of two open wings surmounted by a
crescent and sometimes a disc and he has
also noted that even the use of the term
Bahaman is a suggestion of this kind of
claimed linkage now do we have this
claim of a linkage there's actually
little concrete evidence in the first
half century of Domini rules let's say
between 1350 and 1400 of any substantial
migration to the Deccan from Iran in
spite of the fact that of course this is
the period of considerable political
strife in in in Iran itself now it will
be recall that the last ill handed ruler
sat on abu saeed died in 1335 in a
plague epidemic leaving the plateau
divided amongst rival claimants such as
the July reads to the west the injuries
in the Musa farad's to the east and some
decades later famously Taymor it and
invaded the region setting up the rule
of the Tim routes over Iran notably that
of his son Musharraf from 1409 to 1447
so it's actually the latter part of the
three Madrid epic that we see the real
growth and stable maintenance of close
links between Iran and the hominid
Decker and this is actually particularly
we know from the 1420 s on words even
though parish there says that or
really at the time of suit on Felucia
bahaminy sometimes royal ships were
being sent to the Persian Gulf now the
conventional explanation that is given
for the shift from the 14 20s onwards
tends to associate it with the contested
accession of Sudan Hamid family ruling
between 14 22 and 36 who faced
entrenched opposition from the elites in
Gulbarga moved his capital further east
to be the later named Mohammed Abad and
this Suzanne as well as his immediate
successor brought in considerable
numbers of Iranians both men of the pan
and robe and those of the sword and of
course these included famously
the descendants of the great Sufi saint
on whom drawback devoted considerable
amounts of time shanlee Matala relic a
domani died 1431 but there were also a
number of other migrants from Yemen and
its environs in southeastern Iran
extending as far as Eastern who came
into the Deccan at this time now a
figure who assumed very great
significance and who remains a little
bit under studied in my opinion came
from further slightly further west so
this was the figure of the great magnate
hala Hasan Basri who eventually enjoyed
the title of vizier in the bahaminy
Sultanate but also the title which would
be later taken over by a more famous
person of molecular Josh now we can
follow a halluf essence career we are
told that at the time that Sultana Hamid
was trying to gain power in 1422 Slough
Assam was already there as a well-known
merchant that he financed his campaigns
to gain power and as a consequence of
this financial help that he gave the
Sultana
he was then rewarded at the time that
the rule was consolidated and then we
are told that from his role as a
merchant he emerged as a general and as
a general then actually it is he who is
responsible for the definitive conquest
of the conquered in the coast so we are
talking about in from the lake 14 20s
into the 14 30s where he subjugates
areas
as mayhem and salcette which are both
today a part of Mumbai and he also had a
continued activity up and down the coast
fighting a number of local entrench
chieftains and actually he was finally
killed fighting one of those chieftains
precisely in the conquered uplands he
was ambushed in 1446 by the Rajas of of
Helena near Kona poor and we are told
actually interestingly by the chronicler
Farish said that when he when he was
killed and I quote he fell with 500
noble Sayid's of Medina Karbala and Naja
who were apparently in his entourage and
he also says that besides them he had
around him three thousand others natives
of Iraq for a son mother and her room
and Arabia so not only are aliens
clearly there's a number of other people
who are being brought in at this time so
between the 14 20s in the 14 40s we can
see that Holly Fossen was the one who
was playing a role the role of a pole of
attraction to a number of elite migrants
and he countered up on them for his both
his military and possibly his commercial
endeavors now of course it's very well
known that this title of molecular to JA
then passed in the second half of the
15th century someone who's much more
famous and this is of course the great
figure of Roger Mamedov on Jelani who
was the great figure in the bahaminy
Sultanate from the 1450s
to his assassination in 1481 now Mahmood
Guevara and this is of course the most
famous structure that he has left us
behind his mother Stein in the city of
Pisa
he as I said arrived in the region then
he was already in his forties and at
this time he he disembarked in the port
of double he remained associated with
that port through much of his career he
eventually made his way to be there and
he emerged very quickly as an astute
trader he was clearly very very able in
discerning the quality of horses so this
was one of his capacities but you also
had for instance a great
capacity to trade in military slaves
whom he was bringing in from the Persian
Gulf and elsewhere of course we also
know that the reason why that Gavin we
very well served much better than with
Holly Fossen is because he had a very
superior education he had been trained
in the courts of northern Iran and he of
course left us at least two important
works of of been left the residential
and the menagerie Lanisha which give us
a number of interesting sources
indicating his Network you can see how
he continues to correspond with both
intellectuals for instance he has an
elaborate correspondence with Jamie
famously but we also know that he had
connections with both the Karaganda and
the Ocoee Unruh dynasties which had
emerged in the second half of the 15th
century the Russian merchants afanasiy
nikitin who visited the Sultanate in the
fourteen 60s and early 1470s has left us
a very vivid portrait of his activities
he mentions him especially as a trader
and as a warlord but he was also as we
know a great patron of the arts and a
builder and so what we actually can see
is that even if initially our impression
at the time of the 1422 the 1430s is
that there's a domination of merchants
from the southern part of the Iranian
world now already with Mamedov and we
are talking about people who seem to
come more from the Caspian Sea littoral
region so they land to the west mouth
and around to the east and they to find
a prominent place now of course a
problem is this and I've come back to
this problem that we can't actually we
don't have to date a proper prosecco
graphical analysis of migrants because
the Deccan chronicles are too unwieldy
so far no one has had the patience to
really trawl through them to work on the
place name news buzz to to get a proper
sense of who came from there but if we
actually looked at the 15 century
references we would find a lot of people
with names such as Golani Astra body
comb a sim nany our destiny
Sistani and so on now by the turn of the
sixteenth century by the early sixteenth
century this flow of men which passed
principally through the Persian Gulf
island and on Tripoli Hormuz came to be
divided into several subcategories now
Jean Val who was I think the closest
called a closest reader of these
materials has provided us the following
synthesis which I will read translated
into English I quote India did not just
drain precious metals from Iran it also
drained men who moves was to the princes
of the Deccan a place to recruit
mercenaries who were emancipated slaves
all armed those whom the Portuguese
sources term white people in contrast to
the indigenous competence competence or
African forums as the dark darker skin
who were less valued on the military
labor market whoever has more white
people gent Branca is the most powerful
observes to me peevish who in the 1510
estimated that ever tend to twelve
thousand Persian warriors in the deck
that's quite a lot of these warriors
originated originating from Iran a good
number of ethnic ducks as a result of
tribal disorders that were linked to the
successive fortunes in the courts of the
fifteenth century in the early 16th
centuries karaköy in low octoroon low
Safavid Kissel Bosch and took men from
Iran evicted from the usual territories
cut off from their clans or threatened
by vendetta's moved to India in groups
or as individuals either wire the
Kandahar route or more frequently by sea
amongst these uprooted men who would
seek their fortune in India a good
number also native Iranians members of
initiatory Brotherhood's of wrestlers
who preferred adventure and the Miche of
war to the sad lot of artisans or
peasants you can see that it was a
district rat excitable back there some
of these the end of the quotation some
of these had specialized skill skills
notably the archers who came from the
south they are what I call and in the
vocabulary of the PDF frequently seguir
portion
because they had the special archers
ring to protect them when they were
pulling the the bowstring from which the
many of them came in particular from the
southern region of Lara Stan
in one of his letters to the Prince of
LARC Muhammad Gavin actually writes off
his pressing need in the matter and it
seems that he actually had a special
agent based in Hormuz whom he was using
to recruit these men once again I fight
obba brigand enter immigration
these were the alternatives that were
all too often offered to men from the
poor villages of the Gallants here at
whose races could often not feed them
unquote I'm not longer after mammoth
Gavin's execution on trumped-up charges
in 1481 we know that the bahaminy
sultanate began to fragment and regional
power brokers assumed increasing power
at the expense of the court in bitter
two of these post memory state sort of
very limited significance these are the
states of bear R and B the himself
the remaining three are interesting
studies in contrast so you have a
Madonna graph which you can see hived
off the northwestern section of the
family Sultanate including the port of
travel as it turns out and this was
founded by Ahmad Nizam Shah who was the
son of a certain nizam al-mulk berry who
was reputedly a Brahman convert to Islam
though this is very likely to be as
likely to be a genealogical tapas as as
anything else
the second Sultanate very interesting to
its immediate South is the social net of
Bishop ov and this was founded by use of
a Jahan whose genealogies are so many
that none of them can be thought to be
worth anything except for the claims
that they are trying to make by the end
of the sixteenth century one genealogy
claims that he was descended from a
fugitive Ottoman Prince another claimed
that he was in fact of a noble origin in
Iran itself but the most plausible of
the stories is to be found in a
chronicle of refugee Shirazi the tsk
rattle mu Luke and shirazi actually
makes the very interesting point and the
point to which I will return that
chillie very likely you so far the son
was of humble origin and we know that he
was at any rate brought as a slave to
India by a merchant called Frizzell El
Abidine sim Lani he himself acted in the
horse trade but what is also
particularly interesting about him was
that he had a reputation as to things as
a cook and as a wrestler and in fact the
stories that are recounted about his
origins are very interesting stories
because they suggest this clearly
deserves sort of Seti folk origin
stories that he was he was a cook in the
in the in the bimini kitchens and but he
was also someone who was known for his
capacities as a kind of Parowan and what
in fact happened is that a great
champion wrestler came down from Delhi
no one could defeat this wrestler does
the question of Deccan e pride and
finally it was Yusuf who was able to
defeat him and from then we see his his
his ascension now this is in fact a very
interesting theme which appears on a
number of occasions and I'll come back
to it which is the capacity of some of
these lowly Iranians not people of great
origins to actually master these various
forms of martial activity so you have
the you have the artists whom we have
already seen but in fact these these
Iranians are often associated with a
hybrid techne word which is the word
yeah Colin which is which means
literally one limp technically we still
have the word in Hindustani today we say
we call it a Cong it's actually a word
for a handicapped person also
but yeah Chong is actually a form of of
combat in which someone actually in a
weight does not use one arm uses the
other either with the staff or with a
sword and combats in a kind of single
combat situation and he was clearly
someone who was considered to be very
proficient in this form this form of
relatively humble calm combat now the
tired of the Sultanate
is the is distinct from these two
because of the identity of its founder
the sultanate of golconda on the other
hand was founded by someone who actually
did have a an elevated or relatively
elevated lineage which was a certain
Sultana holy who was actually a prince
of the caracal new house and his origins
actually was studied in some detail in
what remains still the most convincing
study of the subject which is by
Vladimir minorsky a good number of years
ago and we know that satanically a first
visited India as a child he then
returned he faced difficulties with
their poilu then he came back entered
into bomani service and eventually hide
off the eastern or Telangana parts of
the domains from about 1507 when he took
the title of Sultana coley-cole milk now
it's interesting that the Portuguese who
had arrived in India about ten years
before this were quite aware of the
difference in status between these three
salons
so for instance Tommy parish whom I've
already coated says that it's to be
noted that the Sudan's of a manager and
Bishop or were slaves by origin but that
suit on Holi was not a slave he's a man
of great work and highly esteemed in the
land muy triste Amado
natella so we know that he had a
different status and we see that this is
not the only reason but it's one of the
reasons why actually the trajectory of
the relations between Iran and Golconda
will take on a slightly different form
than those with the Sultan it's further
further to the to the West in fact in a
very peculiar way
Golconda it is which retains the closest
cultural links in a certain sense to to
Iran
more so than its its western neighbors
now of course part of the difficulty was
that at the time of Sudan play and his
immediate successors the coast was still
not under the control of these rulers
that was only done towards the middle
decades of the 16th century and from the
middle decades then the Sultan's of
have access to two major ports much
laburnum and Mazama Putnam and from
there they can slowly begin to develop
the maritime links into Southeast Asia
and then eventually in the early 17th
century into the Red Sea and the and the
Persian the Persian Gulf
I suppose the rise in consolidation of
these three Susan it's ambered Lockerbie
Jaipur and Golconda obviously
correspondent very closely in terms of
chronology with the Safavid consular
consolidation itself we will note that
she smells famously of course seized a
breeze in 1501 so that pretty much is
about the time when the rulers of gold
Condon and a bishop or are emerging now
we also know that Safavid rule extended
very quickly into the Persian Gulf and
therefore through the Persian Gulf began
they began links between the Safavids
and certainly the ports of of western
India now um because of this whole
situation then often of a Safavid
presence and then a presence of these
iranian elites in the Deccan the
Portuguese who had for their part
settled in Goa but also had a presence
further up the coast in a child for
instance where they had a fort kept a
very close eye on this matter the
Portuguese often didn't understand
exactly what was going on and for
instance the Portuguese for a long time
had very confused understanding of what
in fact she is and was we know famously
that in the first two or three decades
of the 16th century the Portuguese tried
to make the very curious argument that
the 12 Imams were a distorted version of
the 12 apostles and that therefore the
Xi's were inherently closer to the
Christians and the Sunnis of course
little by little the scales fell from
their eyes and by the middle decades of
the 16th century they have a much
clearer notion of the differences
especially in relation to the ottomans
which was their their main main main
interest the portuguese of course also
had another issue which creates a
problem in reading their sources which
is that they were much given to
conspiracy theories so they have the
view that
there was always a kind of a potential
grand alliance of all the Muslim powers
across the Indian Ocean literal which is
going to emerge against them and they
would frequently claim that all kinds of
embassies were being exchanged with the
sole purpose of destroying the
Portuguese and their their maritime
Empire embassies were indeed exchanged
as we see what their purposes were often
much more complex than what the
Portuguese actually thought they were
but in fact the Portuguese sources give
us some insights into some very curious
and interesting figures aspects of whom
are very well known to us from other
sources so for instance consider a very
prominent figure of the 1530s and 1540s
which is a grand person H who actually
crosses the vessel in diversion from
Iran and settles down in the Amador
Sultanate and this is Shah tidal sani
now of course say he was a very very
prominent figure among the Mohammed Shah
in his re smiley community in northern
Iran he had a very significant following
there he already got into difficulty
with shy smile in the fifteen tens he
was for a time protected by the south of
it court where he had he had friends but
by the fifteen late fifteen tens his
execution was ordered he fled and
embarked on ship from Hormuz to Goa and
from Goa
so he actually embarked in a Portuguese
ship and then from Goa made his way to a
murderer after trying to settle in
Bishop or where his the ruler did not
greet him with great enthusiasm now I'm
in a mad lager he became a person of
huge importance in Cortland life and
what is also of course interesting is
that he concealed the fact that he was
an Israeli he actually claimed to be a
Twelver Shiite and actually managed to
propagate Salva schism in the am another
court he also managed to restore himself
somewhat into the good books of the
Safavid regime as a result and he
actually played the role of diplomatic
intermediary between shaft Hamas and the
Deccan Sultan's on wanna talk
but what is really interesting is if you
read the Portuguese letters they
actually know him quite well he had come
to Goa he maintained business dealings
with the Portuguese and letters for
example which mentioned that he had left
behind a son and daughter and Hormuz and
that he continued to trade through them
and they also mentioned that he controls
some of the ports of the of the Konkan
danda raja puti shriwardhan and so on
and that he's someone who's a a figure
to be to be reckoned with
a second figure on whom I want to spend
a little bit of time is quite a
interesting figure so this is just to
give you a sense of the of the bishop or
royal dynasty as is depicted in one of
these famous genealogical paintings of
the late 17th century as you can see
with Yusuf Ali Shah the dynastic founder
seated with his boot on the underworld
and then his descendants on on either
side but the figure whom I want to
discuss someone who emerges at the time
of use of waddle the showers of other
Han and remains the dominant figure for
almost three and a half decades until
his death in 1543 and this is the figure
someone called Yusuf nari but who
eventually gets the title of firm as ad
con Larry sometimes miss written without
the iron to make him the lion when in
fact he's the fortunate han and this man
was a great figure in the politics of
the Deccan and of the Bijapur Sultanate
for several decades finish that was
fascinated by him and actually devoted
long pages to his career but actually
what is very interesting is that the
potion is chronicler on the barish was
equally fascinated by him and devoted
many chapters to his activities in the
in the Deccan the Portuguese referred to
the fact that he was already present in
1510 at the moment when they conquered
Goa he was fighting on the Bijapur aside
he then played a significant role in the
transition between yusuf and a smile
adil shah around 1510
and we learn from them that he actually
emerged as the great power holder in
this spot yeah which is belga which is
today in in northern Karnataka but which
was actually his power center
he's usually called by the Portuguese
senior the Billy Gong the the lore of
Belgium and as you can possibly the son
because he was there he was actually the
immediate neighbor of the Portuguese
here's his writ ran all the way to
ponder and beyond some of you who will
know the geography of Goa will be aware
today fonda is a part of Goa but that
was because it was conquered as part of
new conquest in the 18th century in this
in the 16th century ponder was to the
part of bishop or of bishop of
territories and Assam therefore appears
honor in all of these texts as extremely
formidable figure controlling huge
resources almost determining the rhythm
of the expansion of the Bijapur
Sultanate in relation to regenerator on
the one side and in relation to am a
blogger on the other we also know that
he is responsible for not the actual
construction but the consolidation and
major improvement of Belfort right which
you see which you see in a 19th century
photographs over here and not only did
they do that he actually built a very
impressive monument there which is the
mozilla sofa which is the the great
mosque of Begum even today it actually
has the foundational inscription and I
will read it you to you rapidly which
which marks its foundation and its
presence then so by the grace of the
power of the master of the conjunction
possessing the marks of royalty who see
it is high and whose throne is like the
sky and whose place is at Sidra on an
auspicious day by the grace of the Han
Assad huh a house was founded and
completed such that its doors as the
Qibla of the hopes of the people of
Islam and it became the refuge in
shelter
slam and the abode of peace kings and
famed people from the deccan endowed the
high fortune salute his threshold each
morning and evening last two lines
composed and written by Cosima's Ahmad
Dean as Diwani
in the year 924 that is 15 1819 there is
a second inscription again where he
talks about how he built this mosque the
time of just one of the age the Son of
of other hand now you can actually see
that this is and remains a very very
interesting in an important structure
but there's another aspect of a son
which i think is worth remarking on so
he remained a hugely important figure
until his death in 1543 on his death in
1543 there was an enormous confusion
which broke out because in the last
years of his life he began to try and
mount an alliance with the portuguese in
order to displace the ruler of Bijapur
and substitute him by another prince of
the earth family this may have had to do
with the fact that ibraheem other shall
the third ruler of apud had had moved
too soon ISM and so there was clearly
some some tension as a as a consequence
now we know that one of the things that
happened was that on his death in 1543
he had left a huge amount of money which
represented his sort of liquid treasure
in the hands of a great Iranian merchant
called Raja shams of gin Gilani who was
actually on functioning out of the ports
of the west coast and the Portuguese
tried to get hold of this money from
Hajus Ramesses we actually got hold of
of a sizeable sum of it but most of it
most of it escaped them so he appears is
this magnet for the huge amount of
resources inordinate political ambitions
and so on but that's not the only thing
which is interesting about him which is
that of course the fact that today if
you go to Bill Gow his tomb is an
exchange dargah as it is is an extremely
important spot now we know this is the
case already in the 17th century but it
was suddenly the case by the late 18th
century when we know that actually
some of the Murata administrators of the
region actually put money into it and
here for instance is what a colonial
ethnographer wrote about this tomb in
the 19th century says assets han who
died at Manderley three miles southwest
of Belle Gunness very buried there is
held in high order by all belgaum bustle
months he was remarkable for his
judgments talents and learning and for
his physical strength and prowess as a
swordsman so you see again the pehelwan
from large who emerges again someone of
humble origin who emerges through his
physical strength others Kearney says is
supposed to have died at the age of 150
and it is said but with little truth
that as long as his memories honored
well gone will be free from cholera in
the muharram all the beers
sponges are brought and pay the respects
at us as costumed about 30 royal
umbrellas hang around the shrine at
about two dozen ostrich eggs near the
front of the building our presence
offered by us our hands devotees almost
all classes of natives and especially
the sepoys pay the devotion at our hands
trying their insolence flowers and
coconuts of the value of about one pound
sterling or offered every Thursday and
dancing girls pay the respects by
dancing before the shrine every Thursday
night does the original building as I
said up front was added by a maraca
mamata of Dagon
it is also interesting to see that if
you look at the ethnographies which were
produced not of the of the dargah i was
fortunate enough since i couldn't obtain
photos of it myself i sent to turkish
invoice of my own so thank you to the
jamilka father and golden age' bolo for
these photographs so this is the the
tomb of of auntie kala moussaka Lari
Pasha and may you see the interior of
the tomb so um if you actually go to the
the fort we are told that there are all
these things which are in the force just
a sword which is kept concealed but
which said no human being could lift
only as a conquered lifted there is a
place which is approximately about 11
feet high
every day he jumped from the ground to
that to the type so he actually has
emerged as a kind of a as a local sort
of super Superman figure because these
miraculous powers protecting the area
from cholera and so on and so forth and
and again it's interesting to see how
this is actually associated with someone
who actually comes from the popular
stratum of a kind of an of an Iranian
Restless swordsman culture and who
inserts himself into this quality rather
than some one of the more elite variety
now of course the elites eventually also
had their say and if we turn from be
Jaipur to Golconda and that's where I
will I will bring us to close in about
ten minutes you will see that in the
case of golconda be the social
distribution of the migrants seems to be
somewhat different the number of people
who are of elite origins is considerably
higher right in the very beginning we
know for example already in the middle
decades of the 16th century there was
someone called Mostafa harm or destiny
who was more or less a crucial figure at
the time of Ibrahim cut up shop in the
1550s and 1515 60s now of course a
difficulty is that we cannot as I said
actually engage in a proper person
photography of these migrants the
Japanese historian Musashi haneda as it
happens also a student of Zampa has
attempted a kind of an analysis where
he's tried to give you a sense of this
migration but the problem is that his
analysis is biased towards the Mughals
because the Mughals kept biographical
dictionaries so with the two great
mobile biographical dictionaries the
haters of Haneen and then the Marcel
kumara we can actually look at that
migration i'm the impression that Haneda
has is that most of the migrants he says
came from the east and southeast from
areas are for asan and quest and there
were some people from
central regions such as esfahan and
convene but he says for example that he
could only find one person who came from
Tabriz I have a feeling that if you
actually go to the Deccan and if you
actually analyze the Technic chronicles
you will get a somewhat different
distribution I think you will find in
the sixteenth century a much greater
presence of people from the south from
for instance notably Lara Stan you will
of course find a number of people from
the Caspian Sea littoral and again the
question of how many sides which is a
preoccupation of Hannah des is an open
question and again I think that the
numbers would be somewhat different if
you were in the Deccan and if you were
in the not hundred ah for instance has
traced some of these say careers with
great care for instance there is a
certain limit mama Amin of shareist Ani
origin settled in Isfahan who first came
to the Deccan and then eventually fell
out of favor moved back to Iran and then
eventually moved to the Mughals there
are actually several people who
triangulate between Iran the Deccan and
the Mughals miss fatale Asha Raji for
instance very famously and actually if
you look at the writings of the Mughal
poet laureate phase II who visited the
Deccan in the early 1590s it's quite
amusing because in the 1590s Phase II is
actually very interested in the idea of
going and poaching the Iranians from the
Deccan and bringing them to the Mughal
Empire and he actually acts as a kind of
talent scout he goes to these different
courtly centers and and looks to see who
is here who counts for something right
so for instance he notes that in the
year that he was in Amur tiger he says a
good number of ships came from Hormuz
there was a certain Haj Amin I who was
the Amida to jar there was a number of
people who were there for instance some
of them closely associated with the
disgraced suffered noble noble jakob
hanzelka that but he actually also
notices that there were quite a lot of
interesting people who were prominent
scholars
in fact that is one of his main
preoccupation sporting scholars of for
instance the famous Takeda Muhammad
who's known as pajama Saba who was there
there was for instance there was share
Bogdan Isfahan II he also mentions these
two great poets Malika me and milazzo
Rudy who were there in the deccan he has
a preference for zu t because he says
that he's more extroverted whereas
kameez is shy and retiring but we
actually can see from that kind of
window that that fez e provides us that
there was a kind of a sense that the
deccan actually had many more Iranians
and in a way the cream of the crop
whereas those who were coming through
the Kandahar route into the Mughal
Empire at this point in time in the
1590s were well less important and for
instance the gold corner quote and this
is the Golconda quote of muhammad holy
coat of shah at the end of the sixteenth
century it was clearly one such center
which attracted a large number of these
of these very accomplished accomplished
Iranian many of whom we can actually
trace with with some care and I just
want to mention a couple of things
before I I close out I must say of
course that phases is the source or
partly the source of the famous very
nasty rumor about the two thumbs of
golconda right which is the idea that
this suit on had a sort of love affair
with a prostitute and that as a
consequence this prostitute who was
called basmati according to him gave the
name bargain either to Hyderabad whereas
in fact first of all the city is not
called bag nagar but dogma that the city
of gardens and this story of course was
a rumor spread against Muhammad Coleco
to Robert
but Prezi of course says about her she
was a what is he the term uses fire
Kohana marcia guy much of a theme of
this of this of this ruler this is old
prostitute and then you know his
greatest love now i'm the great figure
of course when we know from Golconda
history at this time is a science figure
right which is this figure of mere
moment moment subject of a still very
interesting biography by the great
Hyderabadi entry intellectual Zoar
written in the middle of the last
century he of course is the figure who
is important in and of itself he of
course is responsible for the for this
whole quarter which is very very close
to the Charminar which still houses one
of the most important cemeteries
including his own tomb but also the
tombs of a vast number of other iranian
and and other notables amid more
movement Astrea body who is known to us
also for the fact that he maintained a
very close correspondence with the
Safavid shots and we've got quite a lot
of number and that has exchanged between
the two of them and if you read these
letters you actually can see the much
greater degree of proximity between in a
way Golconda and Iran which is
paradoxical given the fact that it's
further away and you can also see that
the the complex relations of sovereign
it is because the Iranian rulers tend to
treat these men who are living in and
being paid by the rulers of golconda as
their own subjects and in a way as
possessing a primary royalty to them
right and what we can actually see is
that the rulers of coca-cola did not see
any contradiction in actually employing
such people and in fact we know of
course the high rhetoric of the letters
from the Zutons sometimes said things to
the to the
Savage Charles for the famous letter
from the deccan which says to the
Safavids that from one of the decades of
dancing that deck and territories form
as much a part of the Safavid kingdom as
Iraq farce Hassan or Azerbaijan and you
can see that there is at least a sort of
a symbolic proximity which is thus
exercised between these two so let me
bring my my top ten to a conclusion
so essentially what we've seen is that
starting from this moment in the
fourteen 20s and this is of course not
to gainsay the much longer relation that
that Abbas has mentioned going back to
earlier medieval or even pre pre-islamic
times but from the fourteen 20s there is
a kind of a new impulse given with this
transition inside the family Sultanate
which leads to this greater and greater
presence of the Iranians in the Deccan
what I've tried to argue is that there's
there are some interesting distinctions
between the migration to the western
part of the Deccan under the eastern
part of the second the second thing
which have wish to argue is that we
often tend in our analysis of this
migration to focus paps excessively on
the elite migration the elites are
indeed the best the best documented and
indeed if we are looking for instance
the kind of materials that Riazor Aslam
was looking at or which more recently
they are doing Shakira's has looked at
the correspondence yes the
correspondence is usually entertained by
these people who had often for instance
made momentous robbery had a career in
the Safavid court before he moved to the
Deccan so you can actually see why these
letters would be preserved in the
initial collections and so on but I
think it's also interesting to think
about the fact that there was a much
more complex social depth to this to
this presence a social depth which of
course expresses itself and which comes
to the surface when there is social
mobility and so in fact there are you
might say two kinds of migrations with
two kinds of logics so the elite
migration is the migration of people
such as the sides who have what we might
in Bude use in terms call a kind of
cultural capitals and who have brought
who bring this cultural gap capital of
being of off-site stock of great
genealogies something which says he
recognizes because he but he identifies
people he actually tells you who they
are in terms of who they are in terms of
the social location but then there are
the others the others who actually are
looking at migration not so much as a
question of transferring cultural
capital but really as much more
migration as in as a means of social
ascension and this is much more the case
of the of the the Pehlwan from the the
Italian Hana of lar who shows up in the
in the Deccan and actually looks at this
as an opportunity to transform
themselves because precisely even that
distance between Iran and the Deccan is
enough to create some effect of
effacement and the possibility of
starting anew especially if you start
inventing new genealogies for yourself
as as the founder of the other tri
dynasty did well and in that sense you
could say that if you actually look at
one part of this this Iranian migration
it is actually not so distinct for
instance from the African migration to
the deck so that part of the Iranian
migration for instance is much more
comparable to someone like this this is
a figure who played a very important
role in the in the bishop hood coat in
the early 17th century Alaska who we
know was one of three or four different
characters who were trying to jockey for
power at this at this time so one of
them was one of them was a class [ __ ]
there was another person who was called
dollar Khan and who was a deccan a
Muslim who it was rumoured was from the
cost of oilmen which is therefore a
relatively humble cost and then of
course you have the person who does
eventually emerge as as the great figure
in the 1630s and 1640s which is to say
mama the main most of aha
who
again from Lara as it turns out but who
would actually become a very successful
general for Bishop or pushing southwards
and would also engage in with with both
Marathas and the Portuguese and Dutch in
a variety of ways so come to conclude
then the Iranian connection would
continue in one fashion or another so
long as the Deccan Sultanate existed and
it can be argued even beyond we can
argue for instance of the Iranian
migration to an influence on let's say
Hyderabad actually outlived both the
sulphur nets and the Safavid dynasty and
we can still find them playing a
conspicuous role at the end of the 18th
century sometimes ambiguous political
role for instance under the asaf jahi
dynasty despite that so many
proclivities so by deftly combining
trade with diplomacy and statecraft so
we can see that these actors thus proved
in the Deccan to be important patrons of
literature visual arts but also built
durable bridges across the finally not
so wide waters of the western Indian
Ocean thank you do a quick you're going
to just see whether there are any
questions
okay let's question that
hi there is a special type of brick in
shiraz which is close to Norristown and
are which is called bat money order a
bat money and and it is quite sturdy and
it is almost twice or twice the size of
regular bricks is there any relationship
with a bat money a place or the
sultanate or the type of building which
they were built and this type of brick i
am not enough of an architectural
historian to be able to give you an
answer to that but i would not
necessarily think that the word itself
would give you a very sound clue I mean
surely the bird itself could find an
Iranian root or it might have been a
recollection of of half an antique past
so but I think the architectural
historians would be able to tell you
better than I that you can actually
trace the relationship between these
material cultures and material practices
so I can't really answer that question
thank you I had sort of a question about
could you speak to the points so you
spoke very eloquently about the
migration that's happening but could you
speak to the points of their migration
might not have been happening I think of
non would govern starting the medusa and
sort of trying to invite yummy and
failing absolutely and not actually
being able to serve as eaten argues I
think at some place that not really
being able to inculcate that mother's
work culture and in the Deccan and then
the turret of the Shia dynasty the third
adage I King converting to self or you
know changing back to soon ISM and what
are the possible frictions that might
have happened could you speak to where
you know the migration might not be
taking place and how could we could talk
recently about that does that make sense
it seems to be the some distinct
question
day so I mean you can see that fact that
Gavin mortar to set his sights as high
as he did that suggests the delusions of
grundle he did he had but I mean after
all you know whether it's true or not we
know the famous story about the
invitation to - to Nizami and and
two-and-a-half is and so on so this is a
there's a long tradition of setting your
sights very high and then not really
expecting or thinking that people we're
going to come but what is actually
interesting especially if you read if
you read phrases letters but actually if
you even read for instance you read the
task area which appears at the end of
badiene is Chronicle is the extent to
which actually Iranian writers and
literature of of high quality did move
now why did they move then and this is
an interesting question which we
discussed it partly in the inner Persian
travellers book as well because some of
the move then they come to India they're
disappointed they go back some of them
you know clearly there are also moments
which were more propitious and moments
that were less propitious and so on but
I actually think that this moment
broadly let's say running through the
sixteenth century and into I would say
the 1630s or so is still very very a
propitious moment for drawing especially
Iranian intellectuals but not only run
in it Alexis I mean I give you another
another you know obvious example then
Iranian scholar wrote a wrote a rather
curious text called carve on a hint go
to Nnamani
and one of his main sources was actually
the the text devoted to the biography of
Abdul Rahim Hana Hana and in the
Marcella Rahimi of the rahim it lists
all the people whom he patronized and
you can actually see how many of them
there were first ocean air money
blotted his own copy book by saying the
reason why people went to India was
because India was a land of
licentiousness and depravity and so
various depraved Iranian intellectuals
went there because they thought they
would be having a better time but the
fact remains that there was a
substantial movement but I think that if
you move to a slightly later period once
you cross into the 1640s 50s
you can see a shrinking and so on so I
think you would also have to think about
it in in in those terms
your other question with regard to the
to the conversion question bishop or is
actually quite an interesting place
because this keeps happening back and
forth all right so the firstly Brahim is
only then ali Adil Shah who rules for 30
years in 1552 1580 is a very devout
Shiite but then Abraham the second who
comes to power in 1581 is very ambiguous
and possibly quite friendly to Sunnis
and then you have a return again now in
contrast to this the Golconda citizens
remain absolutely steadfast which
possibly also explains the fact that
their relationships with the with the
Iranians with this with the Safavids at
least was was more was more stable why
did this happen of course you know we
have the usual factional explanation and
of course Farish they lend themselves to
that because first is this is very
Shiite in his orientation sometimes and
he always tells you that you know when
they have she's and then the deccan is
took power then everything moved in the
direction of soon ISM and when so the
lava cough she takes power then you get
and then when the Iranians take power it
goes back and so on but you know it's a
bit of a chicken and egg explanation
because I mean you could make the
argument that you know perhaps the fact
that they emerge in the position of
power the preference shown rather than
the cause of the of the shift itself
I missed the first half of your
excellent talk so I have dealt with this
so please forgive me
so was there this migration was daily a
one-way migration or was there any
migration in the reverse direction as
one question I have second
if so far with our saw these Sultanate's
as an extension of their own domain are
was this largely a purely intellectual
participation or did they receive any
material tributes from these subnets
thank you though I didn't answer either
of those questions so thank you
with regard to the first question um the
the migration is extremely asymmetrical
so there are Indians you can find in
Safavid Iran but typically they fall
into just two categories you can find
Indian merchants including in the Baniya
Merchants for instance in Islam we don't
know a great deal about them but there
are mentions for instance but usually in
the writings of people like Sheldon's on
European travelers that there were there
were settlements of these of these
traders there but for instance if you
actually look at the Safavid elite the
Amara you have of course it becomes more
complex it starts out of course with
this with the with the initial to
command followers and so on eventually
becomes more complex and of course then
eventually begins to include numbers of
Georgians and Armenians so on as you
reach the latter part of the sixteenth
century but we never find so far as we
can see almost any people of South Asian
origin who actually enter that and there
as we can see a good number of Iranians
on the side of both the deccan sultanate
sander and the models there is of course
the then there's the other separate
little subcategory which is the verr of
course some mogul princes in exile and
software iran periodically the starts in
the 1620s and 1630s but then
subsequently in the period of Aurangzeb
there were others went there but these
are really very very small numbers so
it's it is a distinctly asymmetrical
asymmetrical story now your your your
second question was no we have no
evidence actually of the transfer of
tributes what we actually have is a very
complicated symbolic joking all right so
I mean for example especially once the
mullahs begin to push down on the deck
insulting it the Deccan Sultanate then
almost exaggerated their relation with
the suffrage and and they then make you
know for instance these kinds of letters
which was written are written in that
context but they're actually trying to
provoke the Mughals in some sense and
they're actually trying to persuade the
Safavids for instance that if they keep
the other frontier open that it'll take
the pressure off them but I mean the
Mongols also realized that it's symbolic
so for instance though you know in 1636
when they signed the so-called Treaty of
submission they acquired nama with the
it is to Bijapur and gold could I mean
may one of the main things is the hapa
you have to take the the she Imams out
and it's at that level that that it's
it's played out but actually financial
transfers and so on I mean there were
gifts given in the context of embassies
but it's not as if you can really talk
about it as a situation where financial
transfers a teammate
I could not speak today intermingling of
language who was a dominant language in
that part of India what was the language
in court and how did Persian impact on
the transfer of language across their
two borders yes I mean of course the
fascinating thing and it's a huge
subject in and of itself is that we are
talking about what is linguistically an
unbelievably complex area right so we're
talking about an area where broadly you
could say in the southern Indian
languages languages like Kannada and
Telugu are meeting up with the northern
Indian or indo-aryan languages such as
Marathi and so on right so what actually
for instance if you were to go to the
court of puja poor in the early 17th
century right this is the court in which
people know Persian certainly there are
Persian speaking poets and so on
but for example I mean there is a famous
episode debacle centre and an ambassador
to see the son of bishop or he's a man
called Asad Vikas vini so he's from
convenes in an Iranian migrant himself
and he goes he tries to converse with
the Sudan and then he says that this guy
doesn't know how to speak Persian and he
says that he kept up but it's very funny
what he the way he describes that he
says he kept speaking in the bond market
hmm so that is the Marathi language but
then he had these Russian Brahmins
translating into pressure right so he
actually has these people who are acting
as a go-between
but it suggests that there was a Brahmin
elite inside the court which was
perfectly comfortable moving between
Martin and impartial now of course what
further lends a complexity to this whole
thing is that this period especially the
sixteenth century in the early 17th
century also sees the emergence from the
popular sphere into becoming a kind of a
courtly language of what is called
Saucony
right so decree which is in a way very
very similar to what we would today call
you do or it's a version of it hmm and
what is actually interesting is that
it's not only a language which is spoken
popularly but this is the period in
which the first for instance masteries
are composed in in degree and in fact
the same patrons so some of these the
Iranians for instance very interestingly
will patronize poets who are writing in
Persian but there were also patronized
poets who are writing in degree and so
what you're also getting precisely is
that and of course the I mean you know
that me itself is very curious how it is
it basically you know it has certain
forms syntactical forms it has verbs and
so on which are which are clearly
recognizable to let's say India due
speaker but for instance it retains the
the Persian is often and many many
elements in the vocabulary is very
heavily personalized right so you use
this is actually a very very precisely
interesting cultural product of the
coming together of these different
elements from the non courtly into the
courtly and then also the Michael is
coming from the outside into the Scott
Lee structure
because I always think of something here
you know if we if we think of the
conflict between the if you wanna call
the Portuguese and the Ottomans or first
the Portuguese and the mum looks if we
think of the Battle of do 1508 yeah the
Ottoman memory of joint operation
against the Portuguese later on 1530s
and then down to 1570 my question is the
following here did the Portuguese get
any help from the salt whatever Sultan
is at that time or whatever be just a
matter of affinity with some of it Iran
or was there any indication of some kind
of serious
if you wanna call a diplomatic activity
between the Safavids and the local
rulers in India to counter the Ottomans
just okay well I mean the the relatively
little evidence that anyone has ever
found that the Safavids
actually mounted campaigns in India with
let's say the Deccan Susanne's against
the Ottomans alright
the Portuguese are said to have often an
extremely paranoid spirit so I'll give
you a particular example the Portuguese
always claimed that there was a famous
battle in 1565 right may mean something
to you this is a battle in which the
Deccan Sudan's got together the
technical terms have been fighting with
one another or frontier Wars for decades
and finally the three of them got
together and they mounted a campaign
against Vijayanagar and they defeated
the not the ruler with them the
effective ruler and kill him 1565 now if
you read the the portuguese chronicles
the portuguese chronicles would always
tell you these people were incapable of
getting themselves together why did this
happen and they say it's because shot
the hamas send his a
pastors from one court to another and
these ambassadors then mounted this
conspiracy right and it is an account of
this kind of evil Iranian hand behind
that this whole thing actually happened
and this is how these people these
people got together right but this is I
mean characteristic Portuguese paranoia
because you actually have no indication
on the Iranian side either in terms of
the diplomatic correspondence or if any
other you know suffer with source which
actually demonstrates to us that they
they actually even thought in these
kinds of geostrategic terms of
intervening in the politics of the of
the India in Indian subcontinent at that
kind of level so I mean my sense is this
that and perhaps I'm wrong and perhaps
the problem is that the sources don't
speak to us I don't have I mean this
evidence no doubt had a very clear sense
of their frontier problems of the
Ottomans and they had a very clear sense
of the frontier problems with the models
they had a notion of the of the role
that the Deccan Sultanate could play in
helping them against the Moors but did
this average have some kind of you know
power projection in that sense no I
don't think so I mean I think the the
closest moment when you can you can find
that something I've written about
elsewhere is you know that moment in
around 1600 to 1610 when shower-bath
is looking to see what he can do with
this electorate and whether he can
which of the two openings or three
openings you can find so should we take
the silk trade out through the Caspian
should we try to take it into the
eastern Mediterranean or should he take
it out of the Persian Gulf and of course
he decides in the Persian Gulf right but
that is about as far as you can find in
terms of projection I don't have any
sense of they really thought of
intervening in that sense against the
Ottomans in the context let's say some
distant horizon
yes thank you for your insight what
Sharia law used during that period of
time I understand that version was a
language and there was other languages
but was your Sharia law for example use
inversion during that period that's one
question the other the second question
is you mentioned migration from Africa
and I was wondering where from in Africa
and how welcome were they in in western
India because they would have been Sunni
thank you yeah yes of course in these in
these schools in its Sharia is is is
observed but of course the whole
question is how far is it observed and
to the extent to which it's observed in
relation for food for instance to legal
or dispute resolutions for non-muslim
communities and you know of course our
problem in India in general if you
compare India with the Ottoman Empire is
that we have almost no surviving Kazi
court records in India from the pre
British period we have some respects but
that's about it
and we have theist we have one or two
the document collections of Cambay and
Surat so we actually don't know for
instance there's the whole interesting
thing which Ottoman historians have
shown for instance that in if you're
looking at a city like Izmir often
Christians and Jews are actually
bringing their disputes to the Sharia
Courts we can't say anything about
what's happening in India because we
actually don't have that that comparable
evidence but it doesn't seem to be on
the face of it that that the the cause
is in these sulfur Nets would really
have had jurisdiction over over the
non-muslim communities at any rate our
evidence is extremely extremely tense
now with reductio the other question
about the African immigration it's very
interesting because there are
essentially two areas of immigration and
it sometime is marked
names so for example if you look at the
the people who you find in this area in
both Ahmednagar and in in via piranha in
Golconda eventually most of these people
the term which is used for them is
Sydney hmm but that doesn't is not a
tremendously helpful in terms of
identifying anything but some of them
are identified as have XI and some of
them are identified as Zhang Jie or Zhen
Zhi you know now of course that
indicates some difference in the African
origins the people the Zanjeer would
come from further south and typically
let's say what corresponds to the
Swahili coast and the the HAP she would
normally would have come probably closer
to its your pirate rare and and the red
smooth red sea all right I mean for
instance that's been the most famous of
these figures is a someone called Malik
Ambar and Malik Ambar there's been some
speculation about where he came from the
suggestion which Eaton and others today
accept is that he came from Ethiopia
then there's the further question of
course of whether these people at origin
were Muslims or whether they were
actually Christian populations who in
the course of the slave trade were
converted to Islam and then brought to
India in the case of Malik Ambar
actually one of the things we know was
is that he was a huge extremely
prestigious patron of Sunni learning
thank you very much for this wonderful
talk I have two questions here perhaps
interrelated one is the question of our
simulation you have pointed out to us
that some of these were members of elite
others were commoners and even if we
would consider that perhaps members of
elites would have been that would have
been a creative chance for assimilation
because of the social status how does a
member of common air a commoner would be
able to assimilate into a world that we
have just pointed out in a previous
response to a previous question still
linguistically very fluid you have a
number of languages so I presume that
tertian still not considered as a kind
of a lingua franca in the region but it
was one of many other regions in the
languages so how come that this form of
acceptance within Eden within the court
of the society at large is the so in a
sense easier than most others early
modern societies that's one question and
the second point to that number of times
to kind of merchants who were their
supporters or patrons for number of
these figures who come to do this course
of the can is there a kind of one can
see a economic commercial networks that
in effect supports this kind of a
movement of population yeah you know the
the question of the assimilation or
whatever you want to call it I mean
there's one level at which it's easy to
conceptualize if not to actually always
get into it in detail which is the
linguistic level you can actually see
with that career of ducking if you
instance you can see that now I mean you
know for instance if we look at who some
of these Dakini authors are one of the
earliest authors of a of famous Naveen
Daphne whom I written about elsewhere
wrote a text called fat UNAM Putnam and
Azam Shah about the victory of 1565 of
zionism Shah he's an Iranian migrant his
name is Hasan Chiaki but he writes in
techne so this is some one of the first
ruin of in the first generation is
already actually making the moves to
actually acquire some form of linguistic
expression of course his defini is quite
it's quite elevated in terms of its
highly personalised right so so you can
see that then there is the other
question which is a very difficult
question very interesting question which
is of course the question of the of the
gender relations so we know that
disproportionately most of these
migrants were men not all of them we
know for example that use of other
conferences eventually brought some of
the women members of his family if from
from Iran and in fact in the in the
fight which took place on his debt one
of the things which is very much noted
was how the women is you know expecting
Turkish as they were women off of the of
his family actually you know sees the
inside of the citizen and wouldn't let
it go but at the same time we know that
you know for instance he immediately
married the daughter of a very
significant marathi chieftain and so his
son Ismail is already by ascendancy part
part part Indian now it's very difficult
because we don't have a you know details
of this but I'll just give you an
example which can help us ok so take the
mullahs all right now we so far as we
know the bother and Humayun you know
Indian languages
output was always the doubtful case but
now we found attributed to advert one or
two verses which are in semi in Hindi
but very weak Jahangir right so now we
are that generation along now jong-il
has these very very interesting passages
in his autobiography where he talks
about his appreciation for poetry in
bread Russia head bread washes B is one
of the regional variations of Hindi
spoken in the area of Mathura and Agra
and so on and it's particularly favored
for for singing if you if there is a you
know North Indian musical form called in
purple and the bud is sung in bread
cutter usually it's considered to be
most appropriate and he talks about how
he really appreciated this and he talks
about how there are these metaphors for
example there's a metaphor of the bee
which comes and it was attracted to the
flower and that is like the relationship
between the lover and the beloved and so
on and he says and these are the things
you find in brother Pasha and and and he
shows that he is actually aware of the
fact that this is another linguistic
register which has its own place which
has its own aesthetic etc so you can
actually see there you know and then by
the time you get to Shah Jahan for Shah
Jahan has a whole collection of the door
but redone for himself which is called
the the sastras so you can actually see
that this is this kind of negotiation on
the other hand of course you can also
see that the other side of it like with
Assad Bay who comes and says you know
more of what kind of salon is this he
doesn't even know how to speak Persian
properly because by the time he he says
he speaks she cast and he doesn't he he
tries to he opens his mouth to speak
Persian but what comes out is Marathi so
you also have clearly that kind of
tension between the Persian speakers who
think they represent a higher culture
and then Achilles which are meant to be
lower down
something yeah if I may also ask a
question following up on that and so I
like that - after you I'll pass the mic
over ah trade I'll come to that yeah
sure so a question I'm somewhat
following off the last and this is
regarding the cultural capital embodied
by Iran and also the elite migrations so
you'd mentioned that a large number of
sides are migrating at this time and I
was reminded of a lot of the the Postum
would say of migrations into Punjab and
Sindh Shirazi the the mercury Syed's and
and so on and so forth
cause she's rather curious as to who
these diodes really were and what kind
of roles they were playing and how they
were perceived beyond of course that
that religious symbolic capital which of
course leads leads to a second question
as to what degree were where people
reinventing themselves as diods at this
time and then the second question is
actually one regarding the question
again of let's say the the Mossad which
you shared where this becomes the place
of where one can reinvent themselves
socially to what degree does does raise
enter into the equation in other words
is there an understanding that this is a
desired race and as a result does it
become easier for Iranian migrants to
intermarry and then become part of the
broader elite circle race well you see
it clear to your first question um yes I
mean you know there's an interesting
question I can't remember the name of
the the Japanese scholar who's actually
studied this question of you know the
kind of reinvention of what it is to be
a Syed in the post Mongol post Mongol
world right especially post Mongol post
Mongol broadly speaking Iranian world
and I mean of course you know people
have stronger or weaker genealogies and
but I think that what is what is
actually of of interest over here is
also the fact that I mean you know
you're dealing with the situation in
which I mean that is the famous problem
right the Bengali proverb about how you
know
the peasant in the first year the
monsoon was good and we share and in the
second year of the monsoon is good and
ESA it and so on and so forth so but I
think that the problem over here would
have been somewhat that I mean you're
talking about a situation you know which
you can see I mean I remember the
there's an episode when in the Jemima
feed even when mumble more feed actually
comes and then he moves to this town
that he meets these people and he's
constantly suspicious of them because
he's constantly thinking that these guys
are faking it and are they really who
they claim they are and then you know
and of course you know if the person
claims you know figures from yes right
so he finds that yes D he wants to know
who this guy really is and whether he
can actually show him some kind of real
a genealogical authenticity so I mean
it's not it seems to me that yes
migration may have helped people to play
fast and loose but perhaps not as much
as we would expect I don't think that I
mean so social reinvention I think was
was much more possible than necessarily
claiming you know it sort of the same
problem as you have in India with which
people often ask me which is for
instance could people move 300 miles and
say they were brahmins and they were not
where ever they were three and and I
mean then there's a whole question of is
it possible what is the nature of
verification what is the degree of
social control that's exercised and so
on brother rarely come across incidents
of someone being you know the state
denounced as a pseudo etc I mean there
we know that there are other kinds of
problems which arise right for instance
clearly some people don't want to
intermarry with other people and this
means that you don't really consider
them to be that which they're claiming
to be I mean the Baris aides for
instance have this problem hmm
so so there's that coming back to the to
to our balance question yes I think it's
absolutely the case that that I mean and
this is one of my points which I had
made from the very beginning when the
first time I wrote an article about this
which is that
because you know I had used this to
actually address the famous question in
the Philip carton I put forward of of
the separation of trade and politics in
in diaspora context and my ideas
actually know that trade and politics
here go absolutely Hanan Alan these
people you cannot understand them
without a trading context and if you
don't actually have the trading context
we actually will lose sight of a whole
lot of things including the nature of
the liquid resources which they move
around the fact that you know these we
will actually often move from one
patient to another etc etc and trade
really is that fulcrum which allows you
to do all those kinds of all those kinds
of things so I mean I absolutely think
that this is very much a you know as I
once you know borrowed the term from a
model chronicler where you know Amara
temperatures are really you know twin
fin twins which I joined to do at the
waist you know that's how good sorry
I've lost your second question
yeah not race this of course I mean it
really I I would I would I would say yes
this color consciousness right ah there
is color consciousness also in terms of
actually if you look at Mughal painting
it's full of color consciousness very
clearly people are distinguished in
terms of their complexions depending and
track to status yeah so there is that
but I mean from there to go to race I
think still requires a leap right and I
mean it requires a leap also because we
need to take into account that you know
I mean to be called white for example
it's not necessarily a compliment right
I mean for instance when Europeans are
talked about
let's say in sanskrit texts of the 16th
or 17th century in our Shwetha makka
there are white faces but it's not a
compliment it's not meant to be they are
also called who knows in the same breath
a Huns alright so I would still stopped
short of thinking about this as
necessarily being being translatable
into interests but I think it's a
discussion we can also we can continue
thank you for thank you very much for a
tremendous informative talk much
takeaway and I wanted to see if you
could provide us perhaps a little bit
more to take away on the methodological
theoretical or historiographical
perspectives so thinking of the name of
the lectures here isn't of this
particular lecture there are three I
think really particularly provocative
terms that might be helpful for some of
us to sort of walk away with a bit a
little bit more about how you know well
what takeaways you would like us you
know to have from the presentation and
the obvious one is connected and I just
wonder if you could speak a little bit
more about the lecture you gave today is
an example of obviously what you've
theorized before a connected history
then also about the use of frontier
right and you know again another kind of
very kind of theoretically sort of broad
term and then also actually the plural
of histories right in the choice of the
the lecture series so anyway just
wondered if you could speak a little bit
to those points if you could Thanks yeah
well um you know I mean one of the
reasons why I actually I always admired
over and why I think actually people
like him or any people like minorsky
and people of that generation who you
know
sometimes it's easy to denigrate in a
facile fashion as Orientalist something
of this kind I mean what they had going
for them was the relative I would say
you know absence of methodological
nationalism and by methodological
nationalism I mean in particular the
tendency to to anachronistic remove
frontiers frontiers from one period to
another so I mean when I began you know
doing research and I'm happy to say that
things have moved on since that time
actually and I think a vessel for him
will confirm me in this in this idea the
kind of conversations that you had
between the Iranian historiography and
the Indian historiography but extremely
limited a simply because this was not a
subject which the Iranian disorder if
you would have wanted to to treat right
and then of course the Indian
historiography often lapsed into this
language of you know the afar ki the
foreigner versus the indigenous at
Muslim etc etc and so this was a a real
issue and I think that from that
perspective you know the fact that in
some senses it's pretty self-evident
that you have a historical phenomenon
it's an observable phenomenon
you have people moving they are
influencing the qualities where they are
moving they are influencing the
commercial systems where they are going
etc etc it's something which is easily
documental both through materials in
persian and in other languages but then
what do we make of it and in some senses
what do we what do we do with it now
people call this transnational or trance
frontier or something but it doesn't
makes any sense because where are the
nations over here anyway right now so
it's in that sense that I
I believe that kind of the the primary
airport I believe of both connected
histories is that which takes us in the
direction of saying let's constantly
question our geographies right let's not
take our geography for granted and I
mean not so long ago I was talking in a
very different context of popular
context about something which is you've
been in the news in the last year or so
which is this you know community called
the door hangers right which are or who
are located today on the border of what
would be proudly validation and Burma
now I mean know this is a community
which again you know is which today
faces this whole you know probable thing
will define yourself which side are you
on culturally which side are you on in
this sense and decide are you on in that
sense and so on that is actually sort of
looking at it at this community
historically you can actually see how it
is perfectly logical how they emerge in
the context of political systems which
were you know very integrative of parts
of northeastern India and Bangladesh and
Eastern Bengal and and and another count
so I think that's the the the the sense
in which so I would say never take your
geography for granted now the question
then is with regard to to the frontier
with the door to the frontier I think
here I'm drawing a little bit on a
tradition and a tradition which probably
the best representative of it is
probably Sheraton who from the time that
he wrote Sufis of Buju Poole has always
insisted on the interesting character of
this this area because it's a linguistic
transition which of the kind that I
mentioned to you because it's also a you
know he he like to use the term Chateau
zone which is a term which signals the
geographers had come up with in the 60s
and 70s where these different structures
come together and and collide with one
another so I don't think you know we are
using frontier here and either the
of the American historiography edits
frontier which is a whole other problem
or the lucky more sense of the frontier
which we know from the Eurasian context
I think it's really a much more of a
sense of frontier being a place of of
sort of creative collision in that sense
and then finally why the histories right
the history is is because actually I
mean finally it's sort of the what
emerges from this is one I'm big and I'm
unambiguous narrative of anything so
there is I mean I hope for something
which remains of the switches which is
polyphonic and that excite little hope
thank you for a very informative talk I
the I'm wondering why the reasons why
suffer with Iran Iranian elite will move
to Deccan and we have in various
comments and questions we have touched
on four possible explanations or
motivations rather economic trade that
is the social arbitrage opportunity to
misrepresent yourself as being belonging
to a higher social status thousand miles
away then you can do at home ratio which
has to do with Indian folk Liberty to
assign high value to pale skin and I
guess the battery of consumption of
having good time as he said none of
these have now these four explanations
if I got them right seem like attract
elite from one society to move migrated
to another at least I have difficult I'm
thinking of examples of elite moving for
any of these four reasons East India
Company use little trade and racial
arbitrage solution social status most
people who move to India were from lower
middle class of you know British society
and the battery doesn't sound like the
right explanation why would somebody who
belongs to suffer where they need you
get up and move to chill Deccan I'm
still trying to figure out well you
should actually go back to my 1992
article because it's actually the
question is clearly posed there and the
the additional elements I would add to
those that you have are these so one is
that in suffered Iran in the 16th
century it was just a period of great
religious turmoil right
what you saw was the emergence of a kind
of initially of a kind of a millenarian
heterodox
kingship but then over the course of the
sixteenth century this is model is set
aside and what is imposed progressively
is is the model of 12 of schism and what
it means is that those who are not
to Russia or who have even any level of
suspicion hanging over them like we
solve it shot ahead find themselves find
themselves in an uncomfortable situation
and it is true incidentally that there
are a number of people in Iran sixteenth
century or why they have are suspected
to have heterodox beliefs famously
professors are monitored
of course not the case of the doctor is
who these Muslims who believed in some
form of metempsychosis which is not many
quotients let's say so you have I think
the religious conflict that in fact in
the letters which are written by the
Iranian migrants when they talk about
why they move in what circumstances
forced them to move in for instance
famously they even vomits ie are the
study says that you know we had that
plans and they were seized by the shekel
Islam because the family was suspected
of this on that and so on and so forth
so there is actually there is actually
you know that that distinction which is
incidentally the code what has been
coded sometimes by debauchery which is
the whole idea that you know I mean
which but Ione says very sarcastically
he says you know in the style is it's a
kind of open my dong anyone can come
here and say anything they want and
nobody can do anything to that you know
but this also reflects this this kind of
difference and the second thing which
you also have to bear in mind which is a
simple fact but it's worth bearing in
mind is that remember that the sheer
resources available even in the Deccan
let alone in northern India
I'm the amount of money which is flowing
the liquid wealth which is flowing is
immeasurably greater than what is
actually available in in an area like
Iran which is after all not a very
prosperous region either in terms of
agriculture and to some extent in terms
of artisanal production it is but there
is a disproportion here in terms of the
sheer economic attraction right
and this incidentally I think explains
why for example again if you look at the
other areas from which people move I
people move from high drama people move
from Yemen but do people move from the
from the most prosperous parts of the
Ottoman Heartland to India they don't
alright so there's I think it's fairly
simple I mean there is a famous poem by
renowned poet who says you know that
integrators India India is the mecca of
all in need but he says the mecca of
people who need money
so there's Mecca the real Mike on the
one hand for virtue and then there's
this my cabbages basically to make a lot
of money and perhaps eventually to come
back so I mean we have to we have to
bear in mind that for someone like Assad
salary we don't know exactly what his
fortune was in 1543 but I mean it is
estimated in the hundreds of thousands
of of hoons of pakoras right this is not
a small fortune for someone to have made
even 25 years of a career
I mean but actually I believe go to
video well once more I would like to
thank our structure for the wonderful
talk and I very much welcome you first
of all to join us today right now for a
reception that we have upstairs in the
second floor in the common room and then
tomorrow for the second lecture by
Professor Romania and afterwards on
Thursday we are having a roundtable here
with some of the colleagues from these
three department and other departments
Hardesty department as well and
religious studies up to explore a little
bit some of the seams and
conceptualization of the personate world
and how it fits into the lectures that
we've heard today and we are going to
hear tomorrow and that note I would like
to thank again rick waiver
[Applause]
[Music]